So here's what we have for compounding twice a year with Grant's situation.
This of course is just an example and these numbers could be different
depending on how his account was set up. However, numbers have played their
roles as I've written in here. This number is his principle, the amount he
first invested. Here goes the interest rate divided by 2, And the exponent is
the number of years that have passed multiplied by 2. Now we always like
generalizations so let's see if we can apply one here. I think we're going to
need some variable names however. Let's call our principal P. r will be our
annual interest rate written as a decimal. T will be the number of years that
have passed since the account opened. N will be the number of times interest is
compounded per year. This was two in our example up here. And A will be the
total amount of money in the account. I'd like you to use these quantities we
just came up with to create a general equation for A. The total amount of money
in the account. Just fill in the proper letters in these different slots.
Remember you can use this formula as a guideline for figuring out what goes
where here.